en este vídeo vamos a hablar sobre algo
que se conoce como teoría cinética
molecular que como descubrirás es
probablemente la forma en la que vemos
el mundo y se basa en tanto información
que probablemente ni siquiera pensamos
en ella como una teoría sino como algo
que describe cómo funciona el mundo pero
retrocedamos un poco y pensemos en cómo
se desarrolló la química porque a pesar
de que sabemos todo sobre la tabla
periódica de los elementos sobre los
átomos las moléculas y sus enlaces no
fue así cómo comenzó el desarrollo de la
química cuando la química se desarrolló
por primera vez solo se podían medir
variables a gran escala o macro
variables como la presión hay muchas
formas de medir la presión pero la
presión es realmente la fuerza
multiplicada por el área es muy fácil de
medir incluso si no sabes nada sobre
átomos o moléculas se podían medir cosas
como el volumen está bastante claro cuál
será el volumen de un contenedor los
químicos saben desde hace tiempo cómo
medir la temperatura también han sabido
cómo medir la cantidad o cuánto
y algo en un contenedor por lo tanto la
cantidad y así los primeros químicos
pensaron en la relación entre presión
volumen temperatura y cantidad
especialmente de los gases y los gases
son interesantes porque el volumen puede
cambiar la presión puede cambiar la
temperatura de un sólido o un líquido
puede cambiar pero el cambio en la
temperatura de un gas podría afectar su
presión o volumen y podrías meter
diferentes cantidades en el mismo
volumen en teoría podrías hacerlo con
otros estados de la materia dependiendo
de cómo lo hagas y de las moléculas con
las que estés lidiando pero es más obvio
con los gases y con base en estas macro
medidas los químicos pudieron llegar
algunas generalizaciones fueron capaces
de concebir lo que ahora llamamos la ley
de los gases ideales en la que la
presión por el volumen va a ser
proporcional por la constante de los
gases ideales denominada r va a ser
proporcional a la cantidad de gas que
tenemos y medimos eso en términos de
moles pero es realmente la cantidad de
gas por la temperatura
una vez más todas estas son macro
variables que los químicos han sabido
medir bien desde antes de que tuviéramos
pruebas sustanciales de que existían
cosas como átomos y moléculas y los
químicos entendieron cómo se
relacionaban estas cosas como acabamos
de mencionar los químicos vieron que si
la cantidad de gas y el volumen se
mantienen constantes y si se aumentará
la temperatura eso aumentaría la presión
no estaban necesariamente seguros de por
qué sucedía esto pero vieron que de
hecho si ocurría y si en lugar de
mantener constante el volumen se
mantiene la presión constante pero se
permite la variación del volumen y se
aumenta la temperatura por ejemplo el
aumentar la temperatura dentro de un
globo entonces el volumen aumentará y si
mantienes la temperatura constante
aumentas el número de moléculas y
mantienes la presión constante el
volumen aumentará si mantienes constante
el volumen la temperatura constante y
aumentas el número de moléculas entonces
la presión aumentará y esas fueron todas
las pistas que se usaron para llegar a
esta relación en la que la presión por
el volumen es igual o proporcional a la
cantidad de gas que hay multiplicado por
la temperatura pero luego los químicos
dijeron bueno eso está muy bien pero qué
está pasando realmente que son realmente
los gases y aquí es donde entra en juego
la teoría cinética molecular los
primeros químicos dijeron oye tal vez
los gases son un montón de partículas en
constante movimiento aleatorio permíteme
dibujar un contenedor aquí y dijeron
vamos a proponer una teoría y una buena
teoría es la que explica el fenómeno que
se está observando y dijeron bueno y si
los gases no son más que un montón de
partículas que están en constante
movimiento aleatorio aquí están
moviéndose constante y aleatoriamente y
el volumen de las partículas
individuales es una parte muy muy
pequeña del volumen más grande del
contenedor y que estas partículas en su
mayor parte no están interactuando entre
sí y entonces ya te estás imaginando
esta teoría este modelo mental
tienes un montón de estas cosas que
están tan espaciadas que realmente no
están interactuando entre sí y no tienen
fuerzas inter moleculares luego
aprenderemos que eso no es del todo
correcto pero para una aproximación si
suponemos esto y suponemos que tienen
colisiones perfectamente elásticas con
los costados del contenedor y que al ser
colisiones perfectamente elásticas no
hay pérdida de energía cinética estas
colisiones son lo que genera la presión
porque si tienes suficientes partículas
rebotando vas a tener una fuerza por
unidad de área en el costado de este
contenedor y puedes medir eso en
términos de presión y luego si mantienes
la cantidad de gas constante porque
aumenta la temperatura aumenta la
presión o el volumen bueno y si la
temperatura es realmente una medida de
la energía cinética promedio de estas
partículas y que si aumenta la
temperatura entonces en promedio estas
partículas tendrán una energía cinética
más alta vibran más rebotan con más
energía y luego obviamente si mantienes
el volumen constante aumentaría la
presión
o si mantienes la presión constante o
para mantener la presión constante
tendrías que tener un volumen mayor para
que la fuerza por área permanezca igual
ahora lo interesante de este modelo de
partículas
esta teoría cinética molecular es que ha
resistido la prueba del tiempo y es
completamente consistente con todo lo
que sabemos ahora sobre los átomos cómo
se enlazan sobre las moléculas y los
estados de la materia ahora damos esto
por sentado de hecho cuando aprendí esto
por primera vez pensé bueno no es algo
obvio hasta que me di cuenta de que no
fue así como se desarrolló originalmente
la química la química fue desarrollada
originalmente por personas que me dieron
presión o volumen y cierta forma de
cantidad y temperatura averiguaron cómo
se relacionaban y luego dijeron por qué
los gases se comportan de esa manera tal
vez un gas en un recipiente es un montón
de estas partículas en constante
movimiento aleatorio rebotando en los
lados del contenedor y esto es lo que
genera la presión y la temperatura es la
energía
cinética promedio de estas partículas y
como verás en el resto de nuestra
trayectoria por la química vamos a
construir cada vez más sobre esta teoría
cinética molecular por que en lo que
respecta a las aproximaciones es precisa
y veremos que realmente describe mejor
lo que llamamos gases ideales en el
mundo real hay un poco más de
imperfecciones en realidad si hay
interacción entre partículas las
partículas mismas tienen cierto volumen
asociado aunque es una aproximación
razonable es decir que en relación con
muchos contenedores ese volumen podría
ser insignificante